video on make the video on there maybe I
have to really speed up here daily
bullets no they not daily hourly a
bullet arena and a little bit I turn on
the recording to do a bit late oh that's
a queen so it was a bit hectic now but I
think of pneumonia looks okay yeah we
haven't done videos in the last couple
of days I wanted to do some videos like
you're playing in tournaments this show
ever was my boss my mother's died on me
on Monday and I got a new one on
Wednesday but this isn't all so that
wasn't great this thing really didn't
like it
it wasn't somewhat smaller Mouse more
like for mobile I did know it wasn't
good I actually used it to play my
Wednesday live show just when you form
that's how it worked okay but it's
really good were somehow it was some
really some erratic behavior by this red
is electronic device anyway now I've
come to the conclusion that my whole
mouth was wasn't all that bad
to just died on me but the model itself
was good so I got the same mouse again
don't you take something g500 and the
good thing is that I don't have to yeah
learn it all the new let's say yeah it's
often a little bit strange click on a
new mouse this is okay it's exactly like
my old one
okay the only thing I think I have this
I don't know how what how you call it a
sensitivity I think I think it it is
somehow gliding a bit quicker I know you
can adjust that but I mean I think I am
okay so this is the hourly bullet or in
a quick tournament with with 30 minute
playing time so easy wait
this should be irritating you and it was
irritating come on then winning stuff
not not winning then Bishop c3 wins the
exchange at least maybe this one just
being a pest lol a yeah the move was
probably stronger objectively bird this
is also highly irritating just in my
King is on the 8th this is not so good
wow it's a double check ok and the
knight on a one is still funny and two
exchanges all ok yeah no need to to
berserk and I'm just playing a pretty
relaxing bullets tournament just try to
win some games and see what happens
sorry not show very quickly
okay let's reroute before we get ups is
going to trade long this is ok I don't
mind this much
it's very one-sided position mMmmm do a
cheek this don't think so so I would
like to trade off my light squared
bishop with we should make form and
avoid him void his trades so on this is
g3 is the fruit I should have thought
about this that wasn't that wasn't a
good decision but I was a little bit too
quick in doing it
it's still reasonable nothing
particularly wrong here then I saw that
yeah I won on time okay so the nacho
valium or Azoff let's prove it's not
such a bad thing 509 s6 I mean oh this
is also good a 95 might be playable so
keep this option open for 9f2 I could
have played 9f2 words now I should
should do it ready take the material now
that doesn't really help
let's see if I can open it up his King
is still more more of an issue than mine
I think that's I might that's a night
that's a rule
what a queen trade both is pretty
comfortable there's no check actually
kind of anticipating a chick that there
is no chicken okay last seven points
sounds like a good good distance to the
second placed player I'm sorry you never
know is this number three actually when
she is quick really quickly you safe
through it sometimes those most like
Bishop III they can be really really
beneficial to winning your material
quickly
yeah I'm preventing you from playing
there no you cannot do that
oops okay and get even more stuff here
yeah what trade trade it down not you're
totally can also take this to totally
winning group ending or whatever ending
playing this on
the pointers okay
similar to points off my rating isn't
great and I had a higher bullet writing
but I had some pretty awful tournaments
yeah that I got that restart it was kind
of tricky this stuff it looks extremely
strange but pushing a VA porn bed early
but open good terrible and now I'm
taking this it's pretty much material
for nothing at least I don't see any
anything in particular
now why does someone actors actor fear
so nothing particularly dangerous it
seems good
yeah we get three it's somewhat somewhat
irritating let's just gain some space
and play I'll play for the attack myself
hmm and I could have gone looking one
immediately that's also like really
completely winning the other one as well
okay Wow 31 is hoagie doing yeah is like
three points and I keep winning all my
games that is just winning them quicker
it seems hmm okay give me a game place
that's also not helpful that people play
on with terms of material down km8 it
should be a problem in the long run it
has no square if these are helpful Wow
oh yeah okay after I have to beat them
some chances the thing
it's not ideal here this pollution it's
a bit of a carrot not sure if it is any
good probably not
okay so I can take here I'm funny how we
have to cancel make luckily Luke CH is
nothing it doesn't really work out
strangely enough
[Music]
ah that's a good move and I saw this and
forgot about it that's super-bright some
noodles is this crap game
ah okay ah who the heck is huggy ah what
a sick game 194 summarize to adjust to
this mouse this sometimes weird even
though I had this model reformed someone
not quite the same just have to push the
points now on the kingside I will say
fine it's also not bad
yeah but now this hoodie guy is one
point ahead and I ain't he beat me okay
so same stuff again replaces his
research my stuff and I'm doing
something stupid stupid I might be able
to stick my I hate it
yeah giving people this kind of this
kind of easy game am super unnecessary
especially in bullet chess that isn't
even all that great maybe but in bullet
oh my god sitting the end you have a
hard time to not allow an immediate made
okay I don't think I'm getting chief
mate
you can actually play Chris I drew get
three yeah I'm down on the clock white
go to the outside of course use the head
on the clock now it's much quicker much
quicker I know right if I bring with us
a bit I would have worked actually in
this case sure we should see five is
what that create but okay now it's more
or less over I don't think I can catch
this guy
I was very quick in that game my
opposition was pretty easily winning but
it was just a huge difference in speed
and it's one zero so it does count
Ruby fade and then push the opponent is
a quick win that cannot catch him he's
also very quickly winning those other
games we had left those kind of crap
across eight second then they piled up
just piles up now probably has the same
thing I don't know
come on gimme again I get a really quick
way and that could I maybe I should try
four for some knockouts hey what's this
come on it's funny
pushing the h1 it's already pretty much
winning forward and I just have to watch
out for F to start getting some sort of
stuff on f2
queen h5 coming I have to push that away
and it doesn't it isn't super glam
really Wow No ah crap
Phoenix moving against this h5 nonsense
that's great now okay anyway I wouldn't
have been able to catch him up
I need bezerk at the end
Queeny age is probably still very okay
okay this is a nice position for Wyatt
strategically speaking could have taken
a high but I think I will win it anyway
learn on run what's my wife for that
matter I don't know I guess that was the
berserk high for berserk King this is
all nice and good but it is rather slow
that's the problem we Wow with 1100
capsule in help
it's an even lost one at Daniel doesn't
help okay
yeah one more cannot earn six points
what game what that's crazy that's funny
just creepy hahaha that's amazing that's
really funny
okay I resigned get any points from that
though
boom yeah okay I lost two times again so
he was just too quick them but I guess
it was a deserved win for him yeah okay
guys thanks for watching